prague has the white pieces that means
ding actually who scored the better in
the preliminaries
has chose the chosen star with the black
that's very unusual yeah very
interesting maybe he just wants to hold
with black and
in this manner he will end on a white
ding so he'll end and like with the game
that maybe he knows what result he needs
meanwhile heidi are we going to see your
favorite the nimzo indian it looks like
it yay great if black dark square bishop
comes out now we will see the nimzo
indian defense or ding could opt for the
queen's gambit declined by pushing the
black pawn in the center
forward two squares
what do you think we'll see i think
we're gonna see the nimzo indian i mean
most of the top players when given the
chance to play it
they do it's a critical cutting edge
opening gives lots of fighting chests
and i was wrong we jinxed it we fixed it
it's the queen's gun but declined aha
and we did see uh that thing with the
white pieces though had a great score
with this opening yep very decent scored
ding and i think he's just an expert on
both sides of this type of position with
white with black ding has been playing
these positions since he was very very
young
since he was even younger than prague so
we see the exchange variation of the
queen's gambit declined a couple of
pawns have left the board now white's
stepping forward with his own pawn black
has a variety of different setups
different moves in this position
normally black's bishop comes out
but light square bishop or the dark
square bishop can both develop at this
moment
okay first he challenges white's bishop
the ship steps back
this is actually quite trendy ivanka i
know a lot of top players have been
playing this variation just in the last
few weeks alone
yeah yeah it is uh trendy and uh one
thing i just wanted to point out is that
the white queen by saying
well actually not the white queen by the
black the white knight not developing
the black hasn't been able to trade off
dark square bishops but anyway okay yeah
that means all pieces on the board and
it's likely to stay that way for a while
black's night now has developed and here
usually we see white's queen maybe take
a step forward
connecting the white rooks just
simple development there are other
options for prague you could step
forward with a couple of different pawns
maybe um often we see the dark square
bishops leave the board in uh position
like this but black is a bit cramped
black has slightly less space than white
so any exchanges will help black and
this pawn push this idea i'm not sure it
was this exact position but at least
this idea of pushing this pawn there was
a very famous case just two weeks ago
and uh i think it was fabiano caruana
introduced this move
one hour later jordan van freest played
the move as well and it had never been
seen before that one day and it was
played twice in the same day by two
different players on opposite sides of
the world so a really interesting pawn
push
yeah no i'm glad he said that david
because actually i've never seen it
before so now i i know it this is
cutting edge theory i was like oh hang
on a second that's not normal but uh
yeah absolutely fantastic and dark squad
bishops off the board and this is the
big idea the pawn is just going to march
forward and take as much space as
possible yeah white's idea here with
this pawn push as you might have
mentioned is firstly to gain space
sometimes you can kind of destabilize
this black structure by pushing even
further forward asking a question of
this black pawn either black will take
you and ruin the pawn structure or black
will have to bypass your pawn and you
have this kind of wedge in the position
for an end game this pawn is going to be
very very dangerous
so that's one interesting idea and also
you do have the option to maneuver your
knight into this dark square and this is
a very typical idea because this pawn
lies on a dark square black can never
really break out and challenge so you
have kind of created a semi outpost for
your night and uh yeah this was
completely
new position until two weeks ago that's
how fast news travels in chess all the
top players going for this trendy
variation
when we learn how to play chess or when
we give
good advice to new people who play chess
what other advice are that you shouldn't
move the same piece more than once in
the opening but here we see that uh
prague has moved his his pawn why why is
that a good move um this point forward
yeah i guess uh it's partly to gain
space i think prague has pretty much
completed development now um at least
with his minor pieces the non-minor
pieces are on decent squares very
centralized squares ready to kind of
play on both sides of the board
depending on what they need to do um i
am slightly surprised that he hasn't
moved his queen yet as uh as mentioned
for example um in the current position
he could move his queen connect his two
rooks and the rooks are flexible maybe
they'll want to play on this side of the
board supporting their pawns maybe
they'll want to play in the center later
another common idea would be to just
move the rook across one square later
kind of play for a pawn break in the
middle of the board
you're right there heidi i think he
should start developing you don't
necessarily want to get carried away
with any pawn pushes yet you want to
decide where your pieces go first
and you also mentioned moving the same
piece several times black has moved this
ninth uh twice already
kind of rerouting it towards the
kingside he's also moved this knight to
the edge of the board twice
so black's maybe lacking um in
development compared to white just
because he's messed around with his
knights black i think here ding would
love to get his bishop out for example
to develop it and he would love to
centralize his rook on the next go he
needs to get all of his pieces to better
squares
at the moment i think that's maybe where
the evaluation bar slightly favors white
just because white is
slightly more ready white also has more
space thanks to the advance of this pawn
yeah
one of the things that i found always
very uncomfortable with black um because
i do have experience not exactly in this
particular position is that the the
light square bishop does develop but it
doesn't actually have a role you know
once black does all the happy moves then
uh he just has to sit and react to
whatever white comes up with
and
it's gonna be an interesting battling
ground and i'm just
i love the fact as david pointed out
earlier that this is like super new
theory
you know
like literally from
two weeks ago like you mentioned yeah
and now it's kind of like
but i mean this is just it's incredible
especially when you think about in the
past when uh players took it took weeks
to find new their new ideas and they
were scary magazines and uh actually we
have a very interesting move from uh
white
deploying the the knight to the back row
in order to attack the black knight on
the edge of the board yeah maybe we can
show this because it looks really weird
retreating the knight back to the first
rank as ivanka said first of all there
is a threat that you have unleashed an
attack against the black knight which
now steps back actually to a better
square and i think prague's main idea is
sometimes you have to kind of take a
step back uh to go forward and uh yeah
sometimes it's just like in life you
have to admit a mistake in order to kind
of improve things in future and the
white knight is destined for this square
it does feel however like the white king
is a bit
well i don't say naked but it doesn't
have many protectors around it so at
some point we might see black pieces
kind of gravitate towards the white king
maybe simon i'm missing him in here in
the studio but maybe this idea of
pushing the black pawn forward because
the white king has no defenders and
that's normally a trigger that's a
signal that you should attack if your
opponent has no defensive pieces
meanwhile prague will try and play on
the opposite flank of the board white's
knights will start to jump in i'm not
sure what they're doing there but they
look nice and pretty all right but we're
basically out of the opening now just
about yeah both kings get it going to
safety
so all right middle game yeah and uh but
we we're going to talk about openings
for one second now because uh we haven't
launched a quiz of today no we haven't
lost the quiz a day yes i'm about to do
it yeah and of course you know this is
the chassis ball masters and it's all
about openings and we are asking for our
quiz of the day what is your opening
nightmare
we are asking you to recall all those
bad memories and uh it's a chessable
prize up for grabs and this time it's
the grand royale lopez by uh niels
grandellius he was actually playing
early on in the preliminaries
and uh well in order to
have a chance to win this awesome prize
you have to tweet your answer using the
hashtag chesschamps and yep just tell us
your deepest darkest opening nightmares
absolutely and
later today we're going to deep dive
into the rio lopez opening yesterday we
were talking about an opening that
looked really old the pictures of uh the
the karo khan are you giving some
spoilers well because i checked some
pictures i wanted to find out who's
behind the real opus opening
and uh there weren't any pictures there
were only paintings of the owner of that
opening so it's an old one
it's an ancient
it's so old yeah but it you know has a
great uh history as you'll find out
and uh all this gold with the best
openings are the oldest ones oh okay and
uh okay ding just moves this rook across
one square again a bit mysterious he's
maybe just hinting that he'll push some
black pawns on this side of the board
and
okay the move goes back to prague and
it's all about slow maneuvering and
planning and heidi you mentioned about
your chest strength but how would you
kind of describe your style what type of
positions do you like to play do you
like these kind of slow block positions
or are you more direct yeah i prefer the
slow positions i like to maneuver and
whenever we play at my club i'm normally
the ones one of the ones that sit at the
end
so i finished really really really late
um
because i'm not that good at openings
i'm better at the end game and i've been
working a lot more
on the end game than on the opening so
the further
along in the game you get the
higher my chances of winning okay nice
and i think that's quite representative
of some of the viewers at home the
opening can be so hard to study it takes
a lot of time but working on end games
you found that's the way to
yeah yeah and but i realized i have to
because when i lose i often lose in the
opening so um i have to work a lot more
in my openings definitely so what is
your i'm just going to put the quiz of
the day on you what is your opening
nightmare uh
it's the french defense meeting the
french defense it's the worst i it's so
bad that i uh when you play
um i don't know if i can see the moves
now but when you i played e5 in the
second game just to sort of stop the uh
stop the difference
oh that's radical yeah i know but
because i lost so many games
but now i'm uh i'm trying to learn so
here you push your pawn forward one
square yeah yeah just to uh for example
meet a pawn push with maybe an exchange
yeah and a trade um so just to show that
point french defense it's a scary
opening but it's a terrible move but
then
then at least my opponents don't know
what to do next so we're sort of on even
grounds i think i don't know what to do
and they don't know what to do yeah fair
enough and um we'll talk more about
opening nightmares in a minute but i'm
not sure whether this move is going to
give pride too many nightmares i would
be happy to see this one if i were
prague here as white because normally in
this type of pawn structure if you
compare the pawns in the middle of the
board white pawns point in this
direction so usually white is actually
playing towards this side of the board
towards the queen side black pawns they
actually point towards this side so
black should be playing down towards the
white king
by touching his pawns on this side of
the board
it goes against conventional wisdom it
does actually make a this pawn a bit
weak it's a bit of a target now for
example if the white knight jumps out
the way at some point the white queen
will attack it the white rook can slide
across to attack it as well and uh it
just feels like ding maybe just a bit
uncomfortable and this pawn is going to
cause him a lot of trouble long term
that being said he has stopped these
white knights from jumping in these two
white knights are temporarily dominated
by these two pawns
so i understand what he's doing i don't
like it too much myself but
maybe he just feels that he wants to
stop prag's plan he just wants to stop
craig's knights getting active and for
now that's enough for ding maybe he'll
just put his bishop on this square long
term to kind of protect its weakness
on the c6 square so still very cagey
maneuvering stuff
and uh how about yourself your anchor
chest nightmares
well if well i do have chest nightmares
actually and they only almost always
involve the opening stage where i get to
the board and someone has played the
most ridiculous opening where my king is
being attacked and it's super sharp and
i don't know what i'm doing and then i'm
like this is not my game it didn't make
these moves
and that is normally a quite recurring
nightmare i have to say um but when it
comes to
like opening nightmares is when my king
is unsafe
i i really don't like it if my king is
out there exposed
and you know i have no good place to put
it and well we've seen a trade of pawns
and uh since the circuits of the nights
have been dominated the night takes a
step back and uh set to find itself a
new home yeah maybe heading towards the
center of the board this is quite a key
square in the queen's canvas declined
the players are just using pattern
recognition to realize where they want
to put their pieces
also white does have control over an
open line now
so it did take a long time white had to
push pawn forward once twice three times
um just to create an open line for his
rook but it can be quite effective and
look out for this rook
at a convenient moment moment maybe
entering the black position later on at
the moment all entry squares in the
black half of the board are covered you
can't bring your rook in but
it might be something that ding has to
be careful of
and ding is still not moved his um his
um
yeah his bishop yeah true um and
actually ivanka mentioned that this is
the problem piece often in this opening
because no matter where you put it even
if you put it on a semi-active square it
actually gets
blocked in by its own pawns black's
pawns on light squares in the middle of
the board and therefore this is
technically a bad bishop if you compare
it to white's bishop white's bishop is
actually a really good piece because
it's kind of supported and complemented
by pawns on dark squares pawns control
dark squares bishop controls light
squares this is like the ideal formation
and that's why i slightly prefer white's
position that being said at the moment
black
doesn't have too many uh threats to
worry about i would be starting to maybe
develop the black knight out i really
want to kind of start attacking towards
the white king somehow not sure exactly
how you break through but you need to
improve as heidi says this bishop and
this knight
yeah and uh well ding is definitely
thinking about his plan in this first
game in the final i set out to the good
night to simon his plan is to have fun
today what's happening simon
well i'm in my natural habitat here at
chess pub uh there can't be a better
place in the world you can have a little
look there's not just chess going on
here there's obviously a bit of drinking
going on at this table as well uh but
there's plenty of games of chess going
on everywhere if the camera like springs
around but we do have over here um a
very special guest who has his own
podcast so um i'll just let him
introduce himself uh if you just say
your name please yeah hi i'm david i'm
host of 64 chess podcast brilliant and
we're talking about openings today um
what's your favorite opening my favorite
opening is the carol khan
oh i feel sorry for you there um
sorry ivanka um but we're here and who
do you think is going to win the match
as well do you think it's going to be
prague or ding
i'm a big ding fan but you got to look
at prague nando's games and i mean this
guy he's just he's doing something
really special right now i mean he has
he has finals or something in india like
he has school exams and he's coming and
he's just making world-class players
look like fools i
i don't know i can't bet against him
it's pretty amazing yeah you've said it
correctly then it's quite nice to have a
podcast to be interviewed for a change
but it's really heating up here there's
loads of people having a lot of fun uh
you can come down this is a place in
oslo everyone's welcome you can have a
drink play some chess the atmosphere is
fantastic and i'm watching you guys here
in the studio and i'm maybe having
a little a little a little drink um of
course that's only water because i'm a
professional
but yeah back to the studio
enjoy yourself simon and we will check
in with you uh later of course uh first
game in the final ingestible monsters is
going on we did have a couple of moves
can we see dingley ren's plan in this
game we've definitely seen his plan over
the last couple of turns and actually
the position has changed considerably
since we lost since we last there and
it's all to do with pawns pushing
forward and actually just when we left
it it was this position black decided
okay now is the moment i thought maybe
he would prepare this with a night jump
or a bishop move but no ding is far more
direct he sees the moment to push
forward and i'm slightly surprised here
that uh prague kind of left this tension
and these pawns looking at each other i
don't think you necessarily want to take
black's pawn because now black gets a
nice pawn center black's rook suddenly
this mysterious rook move from earlier
it suddenly looks like a genius stroke
because the rook is now on an open line
so prague decided okay um he just
brings his knight to a better square
defends his center and that has allowed
ding now to step forward again to be
honest i would have maybe brought my
bishop forward to attack the black rook
and just maintain the tension in this
way but now in the current position
after dean stepped forward attacking the
white bishop we do see white's bishop
move
offering a trade and now the black pawns
stepping forward and the reason i'm
slightly surprised is as heidi mentioned
this bishop is doing nothing it sat
there the whole game on its starting
square and white now is the one who's
just spent a couple of moves trying to
trade off a piece that's not really done
anything the whole game it feels like
white's lost a bit of time and uh
meanwhile these black pawns
long term watch out for them they're
gonna start stepping down the board
it might be quite scary any end game
black is going to have a big advantage
because of these two pawns and they
could potentially become a past one
later in the game and why only has one
pawn to to protect yeah um these two
later let's ignore the rest of pawns but
these two are playing against this one
you're right so if all of the pieces
disappear black is actually just going
to win
and uh yeah prague needs to play a bit
more dynamically now maybe that involves
bringing the white knight into the
center we mentioned that this white
knight is on a great square
and uh iran can you talk me about this
one in this type of structure okay he
does play this there's actually a night
fork threatened as well the white knight
wants to jump into the c6 square
attacking the black queen attacking the
black rook
so um this is a big threat which ding
needs to defend against
i'm going to be honest with you here
david i
hate pregnant anders position and it's
not often that you'll hear me say i hate
but i mean it really
is to me a dream queen's gambit declined
and just look at those queen side of
those left pawns on the left i mean just
look at them they're so far up the board
and normally
they live somewhere else and they're
restrained and this is
just feels like it's so beautiful and
also i i suspect that the light squared
bishops are going to get traded off as
you mentioned and
no problem whatsoever for ding yeah i
mean all you need to do is maybe guard
against this knight jump i'm not sure
exactly how for example you can move
your rook up the board and at some point
these pawns are just going to start
rolling kicking away the white knights
in the process
and you can even gain time kicking away
the white queen if you want with the
pawn push
yeah it does feel like things are
heading in ding's favor and look at the
evaluation bar i'm not sure whether
bishop takes bishop is even the best
move but
maybe there are options um the computer
liking black i think aesthetically it
looks great for black it's all because
of these pawns i'm not sure prague
should have allowed them this far down
the board
and the opening is that so this was the
queen's gambit decline inclined and
i did take a look at the opening stats
here for prague with the white pieces
um it's a 60
percent so let me find it there we go
uh am i looking at the right i think he
has a 60 percent
score there we go
60 score but he's also lost two games
and uh won three games in this opening
so it seems like a risky choice yeah so
i mean it's regarded as quite a solid
opening for both sides but prague lots
of decisive results winning a few losing
a few in this opening
it doesn't feel like this one is
anywhere near a draw uh it definitely
feels like long term i mean short term
there's going to be
imbalances pieces all around
white has the open file but long term
black is the one with the trances so i
can't see this one fizzling out or
getting simplified or being safe for
either side anytime soon
it doesn't feel safe at all for whites
and
yeah i really don't like it i've said it
again i said it once i say it again you
know i just don't see what its pieces
are doing and black has a very nice plan
he has the space
and i mean also i'd like to go back to
an idea that david mentioned many many
moons ago and that was actually maybe at
the right time once you've controlled
everything on the left you can actually
start advancing on the right you know
i've seen some beautiful plans from
alpha zero
where the pawn h pawn of course moves up
the board yeah later on um i i never
know why i it's hard it's so hard to
explain but just in this type of pawn
structure it's always black pushing
towards the white king maybe it's just
because white's king has no defenders
around it uh if you compare black's king
has two nice knights and that's the
rhyme knight on f8 there is no mate and
black's king is always going to be safe
once this knight sits here whereas the
white king no defenders so yeah that's
an interesting point for later watch out
for an attack black can maybe distract
white with these pawn pushers
okay first he trades off the bishops
but
okay wow now he goes for this pawn push
i said that this was a threat the knight
jumping in attacking the black queen but
ding is completely ignored that he's
attacking the white knight now and if we
see white threaten the black queen maybe
the black queen just moves and after the
white knight captures this black rook
suddenly we see a situation where black
is temporarily down a rook for a night
but this white knight is almost trapped
it has nowhere to go to apart from the
side of the board and then suddenly look
at plaque's pawns we talked about the
black pawns this one now attacking the
white rook and when the rook moves i
mean firstly this knight is hanging but
uh secondly these pawns are just rolling
down the board
it looks fantastic for ding i think
really well calculated now in the
current position i don't think parking
lander can get greedy and jump in with
his knight i think he would actually
lose if he did this he just needs to run
away with his other knight but that's a
step in the wrong direction if he jumps
back with his knight black is left with
these glorious pawns as heidi mentioned
is two versus one on this side of the
board short term and long term that's a
big big problem for white if you compare
white pawns these pawns are just going
nowhere
it's uh definitely an advantage ding
right now yeah those black bones look
scary and if you were sitting on this
board with the white society how would
you feel i would uh not be very happy
yeah it feels it feels like the black
pawns are coming so close and where are
you supposed to yeah put your knight um
i would feel like i would just have to
defend the fen defend and yeah i would
not like it at all and i'm quite
surprised it it feels like it changed so
quickly i think uh pride looked so
confident he looked like um
he was going in the right direction and
now it just seems like he he couldn't
couldn't handle it yeah and actually
talking of the knights white's knight in
the center of the board on the e5 square
next to the white queen that has moved
six times to get there this other white
knight that's just retreated just
stepped back that's moved twice so he's
lost a lot of time with his knights and
especially the knight that's moved back
not a great piece anymore the knight in
the center of the board looks great but
it might just get traded off at some
point and then you've lost six or seven
moves
and in the meantime black has used those
moves to start pushing his pawns
yeah it feels like prague is maybe just
playing move by move but uh ding has got
a bigger long-term strategy in mind
and now okay white's knight is safe so
that threat is in the air the other
knight jumping to attack the black queen
i'm sure ding will deal with that though
maybe one of the black rooks will move
maybe the black queen can move
lots of choice lots of pleasant choice
for dean
i know a lot of people who watch chess
play on an app or play against friends
and and one of those things that might
be quite difficult is when to push the
poles like you know now they're quite
far ahead but when do you actually try
to move them forward definitely that's a
very good question um i guess the first
thing i would be looking for here for
ding okay he actually challenges uh this
open line i mentioned this was an open
line he challenges with his rook yeah
the first thing i would be looking for
here is okay can i push my pawns but the
other thing you have to kind of this is
the hardest thing in chess
simultaneously juggle what you want to
do and what your opponent wants to do
and uh your opponent here has this big
threat of the knight jumping in as we
showed attacking blacks queen and rook
so first i would want to deal with that
and uh also
again it's it's such a hard decision
when to push these pawns i think at the
moment this square is covered
sufficiently it's covered twice by white
so you can't really push this one you
don't necessarily want to push this one
either because you block up your own
pawns
often actually pawns are much much more
i mean they have better potential when
they are side by side like this that
means you tease your opponent you every
move your opponent has to worry about
one pawn pushing forward or the other
one pushing forward you don't really
want to for example just block things up
and lose the integrity of your pawns
because now for example what now is
completely blocked up you need to
definitely um i think when in doubt just
keep your pawns side by side that's the
general rule um just because
yeah they uh they are more flexible this
way it's not clear which one is pushing
but in the current position there was a
threat so ding moves his rook across
also long term stuff like having a
potential past porn
that actually becomes much much more
important in the end game
because the pawns will be harder to stop
if white doesn't have pieces to stop
them with
so i think ding's strategy of trying to
trade off rooks
that helps long term because then the
pawns will become even better
and yeah i think that's a good point i
mean
i've really struggled with pawns i still
struggle with pawn structures sometimes
um unfamiliar pawn structures especially
and meanwhile okay white's knights are
looking okay i don't really know what
they're doing everything's defended but
uh they look okay for now
yeah and uh i think looking okay is okay
it's good when you need to be dynamic um
at least one night starts what has eyes
on the pawn in the middle of the board
which could be potentially quite weak
yeah black's defending it sufficiently
for now with one night but as you might
mention it's a target
and uh white is doing the right thing
you have when your opponent has strong
pawns you need to target the base of the
pawn chain
so this is the furthest back pawn the
protector
so you want to target the protector if
this pawn falls the rest of black's
pawns might fall so that is what prague
is trying to do meanwhile and we also
always talk about that f5 square the
knights on f5 will thrive both of the
knights are very close but they are not
on f5 how big of a difference is it in
this position yeah it's quite a big
difference you're right kaya the white
queen she looks nice and pretty on the
f5 square but she's not actually
threatening or doing anything um
again she's more worried about her own
appearance than uh
than actual kind of
influencing the game right now and ding
interesting decision he's been
consistent he's trying to force the
exchanges
okay this night jump
i'm not 100 sure about it it feels a bit
loose somehow ivanka what do you think
of uh
i mean knights coming off the board it
should favor black it should favor black
um i agree but i was more interested in
actually
pushing the queen back the white queen
you know it's
it's in the middle of the board and some
black side and i was kind of thinking
that that that queen should not be
anywhere over there but then again
it's a solid move i feel i mean it's not
a disastrous move
but uh probably prague like you say will
be a little bit happy to see this type
of
moves
yeah i mean just instinct-wise it felt a
bit loose um i can't see a refutation
though i still
really don't like white's position and
maybe it's becoming a bit uh
time sensitive now if you allow all the
knights to disappear it's going to be
one-sided with black's pawns racing down
also pregnant he has had time trouble
issues and this is the type of position
that if you do drop down to one two
minutes on the clock it's so hard to
handle for white i think it's much
easier to play with black um this type
of position you can just bully your
opponent because you have those pawns
you can say okay i'm gonna trade off or
i'm gonna
try and trade things off you have to run
away from the exchanges
and uh yeah difficult moments for the
teenager
taking under four minutes pregnant now
end game one and ding is as always just
looking super calm
super focused and probably super
confident after beating world champion
magnus carlsen yesterday
it's just in great shape the chinese
very good shape and heidi how are you
when you're low on the clock do you like
playing uh faster games for example
no i no that's terrible i need a lot of
time uh yeah i prefer playing classical
chess i'm a lot better at classical
chess than in
rapid and in in blitz okay so
i normally when i play a classical chess
if i have you know the clock if it's
under 20 minutes you start to see the
seconds count down and then my heart
starts
so if you're in prague's shoes right now
you would be i would be i'll be quite
stressed yeah definitely yeah
that happens to me actually when i've
got less than a minute on the clock i
don't know it's like somehow i spend
most of my energy like looking at the
clock ticked down instead of actually
focusing on the moves but i've noticed
the top players actually
and especially david he's so calm he's
sat there and he's looking and then they
let their clocks go down to three
seconds and then they make a move i'm
like okay well easy for some
others like you it's like the adrenaline
is pumping i'm making some crazy hand
gestures here then everywhere so yeah a
nightmare and when i have like three
seconds left on the clock i don't press
the clock quietly it goes like really
fast
because i can't lose any time
yeah actually i was uh
well recently i played an opponent who
he would go down to one second every
single move and then not just that but
he after making the move he would stand
up and just circle the board he has like
he gains 30 seconds after every move but
he has 30 seconds and he was just
walking around me i was kind of like i
mean i know i'm quite calm but yeah he's
just
i don't know how he does it just ice
cold but did that mess with your head a
bit did he do that yeah
do you think it was his tactics maybe he
had really loud shoes as well that's it
yeah but
okay wow
yeah a night jump i didn't expect this
one i've got to say but not just that
but pregnant he was looking around
he looked like he was disturbed by
something maybe that's just the stress
of going under two minutes now on the
clock and this night jump for white
i mean he's offering a trade of one of
black's defensive pieces but
again it feels so strange i'm again i'm
not sure what the exact idea is if we
jump in white's knight now going to the
edge of the board he's trying to attack
this black knight but for example if i
just trade it off
what has white really achieved here
everything that the white queen is
attacking or the white knight is
attacking they're actually defended very
well and uh here it might be time as
hard you mentioned to start thinking
about pushing one of these two pawns
forward
i'm not sure which one but white pieces
have gone on the other side of the board
and that is normally the signal once
more if your opponent's focusing on one
side and you don't think they have any
threats you can play on the opposite
side of the board okay he doesn't
exchange off this knight though ding
jumps into the center
really brave these knights now make
quite a nice impression but uh okay is
white's knight strong on the side of the
board is it actually threatening
anything that is the question for prague
if he can utilize his two nights now to
form some kind of attack against the
black king he's doing great but if he
can't attack the black king then they
just look silly these nights
yeah what do you think of this
yes
i actually thought he would just capture
the night um but anyhow i here with this
night jump i kind of like it now that
i've seen it i think the whole idea is
to actually step the knight back to
the d6 square and uh
kick the white queen away yeah you can
kick the white queen back i'm not sure
where it goes but uh yeah for example
the white queen could step back maybe
attacking this pawn
and it's still unclear i mean if we go
to the current position uh white is
really here prague is begging for these
knights to come off the board he's kind
of chasing
the black knight around just offering
this trade i'm not sure i would capture
now maybe it's still fine white does
have the option of capturing away from
the center normally we say that this is
positioning undesirable taking pawns
away from the center but you do open up
a line for your rook potentially
normally you should capture towards the
center so you don't ruin your pawn
structure and the white king actually
has a nice safe escape square and
yeah i hear i'm expecting a night trade
finally but
um still feels like it should be good
for black the evaluation did not like
that
move i'm trying to figure out why i
can't see i can't see a tactic
in the current position
maybe you just exchange things off and
maybe just keep things simple and then
start
thinking about pushing one of these two
pawns
yeah i'm surprised it says that much i
know black is better and i think we we
have discussed how black's position is
easier to play because of these pawns
but
it's not winning yet
i just peeked at the computer and the
computer says
it's it's good for what it's good for
black regardless any night move is good
it's like night takes
but the best one is uh
my move that was a surprise
jumping back to attack the queen when
the queen steps back um she doesn't have
too many uh promising squares i guess
you can just defend your central pawn
with your queen and okay ding plays it
of course he finds the best move that's
why he's the world number two and i
think we're heading towards this uh
position the black queen will defend her
pawn and uh now black is actually with
the queen over on this side it's getting
ready to support some of these pawns
marching forward
interesting stuff
these two black knights are just perfect
defenders they actually cover a lot of
important squares
yeah they're the dream nights aren't
they the dream team
no nightmare there
oh
nice i like that one david
it's uh
gosh it's really really tense in this
position you know especially because
pragnanda doesn't have so much time he's
about struggling
yeah positionally you know
he's not down material materially but
positionally he has to do a bit of re
repair work and
yeah it feels like i could actually
swing any moment and well kyle
yay must be good news for prague
it can be traded off
that's the problem the night's gone on
such a journey just to get there i mean
that knight has spent one two three four
five six moves to get there both white
knights have actually moved six times
and no trade yet one of the black
knights attacks the white queen now the
trade does happen so white's attacking
knight did disappear
and
it's all about the knights jumping it's
so hard to explain or even figure out
why these knights have been dancing
around so much both the white knight and
the black knight now maybe they just
balance each other out they're both on
very decent active squares
i just don't really understand what
white's doing white's queen and knight
alone they need backup they need support
to attack
but there is no backup the two rooks on
the open a line they just balance each
other out black's queen does a great job
of defending all the pawns in her half
the queen is cut off as you mentioned
earlier that was a sign and i'm thinking
is it the time is it time now to maybe
get
going with those queens those thorns on
the left i keep saying queen side pawns
today
there are queen side pawns and maybe
about to become queens
yeah maybe even even uh even better
actually so if if he's
able to queen uh ding which of them is
the star is it possible to say already
beth
the bee porn is the star and uh the
reason why i would say beth the b porn
is the the queen because um basically
the knight can help control the queening
square yeah if you think about its
promotion squares ivanka said this one
can be supported by the black knight
later
but not just that this pawn is propelled
forward the queen is basically
like the engine behind the pawn pushing
it forward down the board and i think
there's going to be a pawn sacrifice
next move or on the next few turns from
ding it looks like this point is blocked
for now but i firstly i don't know what
white does for example you just move
your rook somewhere this black pawn is
just going to give itself up in order
for the other pawn to march down the
board and this pawn is going to cost
white a rook and okay prague he didn't
find anything better he just moved his
king
how does that improve the position i
don't know with nine seconds left on the
clock he is under pressure it's time now
i think firstly you can uh i don't know
whether you trade a set of rooks first
but now it might be time to start
pushing this pawn forward a breakthrough
with your other pawn let's keep an eye
on the players because pregnant must be
so so stressed right now
i think he's going to fall to defeat the
evaluation bar says what plus five
that means a new queen might appear on
the board it's incredible actually um
yeah i'm looking forward to the
bulldozer appearing and the the b pawn
making its way to its destiny
then maybe trade a set of rooks and the
final touch would be pushing this pawn
forward or maybe even jumping forward
with the knight and next move this pawn
is coming there we go the avalanche
continues and the pawns yeah this is
what we call a porn storm
these two pawns winning the game we
called it earlier and it's happening
um so an answer to heidi's question
earlier when to push the pawns you just
wait wait wait until all your pieces are
ready and then you support the pawns
with your queen with your knight
and uh yeah he just needs to find the
right way i think prague
uh sorry ding here but prague is about
to fall to defeat it's partly about the
clock but thing's just been another
level it's not one big blunder from
prague it's just a series of small
mistakes and ding has smoothly
taken it
it just seems like the the white pieces
are too far away to defend and the black
pieces are more i can can support a lot
more yeah you're right there
and uh i mean that white queen
has just completely cut off the white
queen's actually on the diagonal of the
promotion square of the black pawn but
black's knight cuts it off
i think the black knight can yeah there
we go take a pawn next move that pawn is
moving forward white's rook will
disappear
ruthless play by ding very very
impressive i feel like this is uh yeah
like you say model game
dream dream 35 moves as well so far yeah
with black yeah i think if anyone plays
the queen's gambit decline then this
should be top of the list of games to
study
um i still i'm just surprised prague
allowed those pawns forward earlier in
the game but
okay what is this trick
the white rook wants to actually
sacrifice itself and to lure away the
black queen because the white queen
remember is attacking a pawn near the
black king if the black queen disappears
then white maybe has some counter-attack
against the black king i think he can
just protect
uh protect a few things here maybe we
jump in just to show
prague he's so tricky here in this
position he's moved his rook up the
board if this pawn pushes down now then
i think his idea is to actually shuffle
across with his rook this looks like a
suicide mission for the white rook
giving itself up
attacking the black queen but if the
black queen gets deflected away now then
there's no longer protection of this
pawn this pawn now drops this is a check
and black's king can't actually escape
the checks if you run this way the white
queen drops back with a check if you go
back the rook drops with a check and
actually you just repeat the position
here the black king cannot hide safely
so actually a really nasty trick there
from ding i think the problem though is
in the current position this pawn
firstly you can maybe just move it
secondly you can just defend it with
your rook and once you defend your king
this pawn again is just going to win the
game
yeah i love that rook move it's just so
small but it's so good as well because
you you renew the threat
and uh super safe now king and rook this
is if they just castled no tricks either
from pragnanda and that's all you need
to do keep control of these wild
positions yeah at this point again white
just has to give up his rook for this
pawn at some point it's too good it's
gonna become a new queen but i have to
kind of compliment prague for finding a
trick like this because you know you can
imagine
if you didn't have too much time on the
clock this is something that you could
well fall into
i think i would definitely fall into
this trick into prague's trap if it was
a blitz game and there we go ding of
course he plays the safest move and
now this pawn is going to win the game
six seconds five seconds the clock is
ticking down and he has to make a move
no
okay he drops his knight back that's
clever as well but the knight is gonna
have to give itself up for the black
pawn it's better than giving up a rook i
guess but uh there we go the white
knight disappears
the white rook is attacked white's rook
can go somewhere but it's never going to
be able to attack anything black simply
has an extra knight
do you think pragnando will resign or
will he can kind of try to fight on okay
he's made a move he's a fighter we've
seen that
i've seen him save miraculous positions
in the tour this season
yeah the problem is for white there's
nothing to bite on there's nothing to
attack white's queen and rook they're
just looking at pawns that are really
well defended black's queen is free to
run around and there we go attacks the
white rook kicks the white rook out of
the black half
i think we might see prague resign in a
few moves you can kind of see on his in
his eyes that he he knows he's lost this
yeah he looks ready to resign pregnant
but he's not going to resign the match
we did hear in his interview yesterday
he lost a game four to a niche to take
it to tie breaks and
no problem he was ready to fight again
and he did win in the blitz tie breaks
he doesn't seem to be too affected by
losses i think it helps him as well that
it's a two-day match
and ding half of ding's attention will
be on the candidates i think when you're
young
it's nice to kind of draw things out
make your slightly older opponents tired
um prague's definitely not going to be
out of this even if he loses today's
match overall
okay pushing a pawn now in front of the
white king
the black knight though just
strong strong peace it's a free piece
and it's a strong piece
i feel quite sorry for prague who had to
have his exam today yeah i'm like why
couldn't his teachers just let him off
for one day yes as well right you know
the biggest chess talents in india maybe
just you know you can take the exams
next week yeah pretty good excuse you
know playing against the world number
two chess player in one of the biggest
events of his life
so far at least um yeah do you find it
difficult heidi to bounce back from
defeats
um
yeah yeah because i start questioning
everything about myself when i lose
chest not just my chest and the playing
skills
like my whole life and yeah
so it's very hard i take losses very
very hard
it seems to be something about chess
with you know losses even having you
question your life choices
and we do have a result